hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on farming and today is
another short dev stream probably the
shortest as opposed to two weeks ago
where that was the shortest I think this
was like 16 minutes so very very very
short a step stream today but I'm gonna
rifle through all this information so as
long as like the view do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes they here
updates the pageant's in the leaks so if
want to be kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
every subscribe to the channel my
Twitter and discord will be in the
description down below and with that
let's get started with today's video see
it's a rifle through everything real
quick because like I said it was a very
short dev stream I don't want to keep
you guys here longer than you need to be
and to not make a 10 minute video and
put ads every minute basically champion
status is gonna be 50% off until next
Thursday April 18th which is pretty
coincidental which we'll get into in a
quick second on top of that a new weekly
Arcade Quest is gonna be out as usual
and the new event challenge is going to
be the be the faction with the most
amount of takedowns to win some nice
rewards on top of that there's going to
be a sale for all masks mythix effects
and emotes that have to do with the
winter customizations only a few of them
but they're gonna be 50% off so if we go
grab those if you're into that winter
theme and on top of that double xp is
also gonna be here for April 12th which
is why I said that the champion status
is very coincidental because if you want
to rank up your character champion
status with double xp is the best way to
go so if I go grab the champion status
even if it's for the 3-day bonus and
then just that double xp and while you
have that double xp you might as well go
on for the weekend and play some ice
brawlers because ice brawlers is finally
back the only issue is that it's only
back for the weekend it starts April
12th and it ends April 15th which kind
of sucks because I've been waiting a
very long time for ice brawler's a lot
of people if you've been in my stream
you realize that ice bars is easily my
favorite game mode and I only get it for
three days which sucks I wish it was
like a week or two weeks but it's okay I
completely understand yeah if you want
to go play some ice brawlers Ledge
people off ice using Raiders shoe go key
warlord and shaman and all those
characters definitely go enjoy that it's
gonna be hell of a lot of fun and then
the last bit of information that
actually doesn't have to do it the dev
stream but infinite a fellow foreign or
content creator within the scene is
actually having a tournament he's doing
ps4 first and then following up with
Xbox and PC shortly after the ps4
tournament is over so if you wanted to
join the Xbox and the PC teams then you
can definitely go
again you just have to go to his recent
video and then wait and then go to his
discordant wait for the announcement for
the Xbox and PC players if you are a
PlayStation 4 player I do apologize that
D tournament is already closed he has a
lot of people and his subscriber count'
that do play playstation so those slots
filled up pretty quickly but if you
don't want to join the tournament that's
completely fine I do recommend watching
the livestream because he's going to be
live-streaming the top eight teams on
May 5th and I specifically recommend it
because if everything goes smoothly I
shouldn't be the co commentator for the
stream so you can watch me chat and
co-commentate while people kill each
other to death and I walk over it so
yeah that sounds interesting to you
don't worry it is like three weeks from
now I'll definitely be keeping everybody
up to date on the discord and in the
community tab here on the channel so
definitely don't worry you don't have to
keep that locked into your brain I can
always update you the day that it's out
so don't worry about that hey guys gonna
be the end of the bait I hope you guys
did enjoy like I said ice brawls is
coming back we got two different sales
weekly quest a new event challenge and
within the next couple days on April
25th we're gonna be hearing some juicy
information about the season 10 here or
what the name is what the moveset is and
all that good stuff so I'm very excited
f we stay tuned to the channel on April
25th which is two weeks from now exactly
today on Thursday so definitely stay
tuned for that I'll keep you guys all
todate with that hey I like the V if you
do enjoy a subscriber for new I'll cover
the informational side of for honor that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patterns and the leaks while
we kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
definitely subscribe the channel
the Twitter in the dis card will be in
the description if you guys want to join
that with that peace out guys have a
great rest er day and enjoy ice
brawler's tomorrow
[Music]
you